you
you know who will come to Oslo in
December to receive the price no
believed that to the EU itself dissident
price to the European make lecture what
was most difficult for the committee
during the process ending upon prior to
the EU of course it is difficult that it
comes when there is so much turmoil and
austerity measures protests social
unrest in some EU member countries but
on the contrary in such time is
important to remind people of what we
have achieved actually we have a good
good framework for solving problems how
critic convert controversial do you
think this price will be in Norway and
outside Norway in Norway more
controversy than in other countries but
I hope the people in Norway can
differentiate between what they think
about know between membership in EU and
the US has played for peace and
reconciliation in Europe many know
people who do that actually during the
history of the Nobel Peace Prize they've
been given prizes to two pioneers of of
the movements peace movements two
diplomats two central politicians to
human rights fighters four people
working for arms control and disarmament
how will you characterize this year's
prize
this is surprised to the organized world
we have good give a price twice to the
United Nations surprise to the fact that
we need to have a better organized world
in order to have stability and peace and
the same goes with the European Union
ourselves some people will have said
that you as secretary-general of the
Council of Europe but that you
disqualify you from being part of a
discussion in the committee ending up
with a price to the EU what is your
answer to the critical voices the
Council of Europe is totally independent
organization it has 47 member countries
not 27 as I have been use of therefore
we have to act totally independent and I
as secretary-general because I am
so-called depositor of the European
Convention on Human Rights I have to
like totally independent and I have read
an oath in the committee of ministers
saying that I will not take instruction
from any government or any authority
outside that comes to our Europe so I'm
probably the most independent person in
Europe today thank you my area
you